okay cool
so phoenix is uh is an incredible place
and what you've announced in phoenix
is uh it's kind of amazing but you know
that's just like one city
how do you take over the world
uh i mean i'm asking for a friend once
one step at a time
is that the cartoon pinky in the brain
yeah okay
but you know gradually is uh a true
answer so i think
the heart of your question is can you
tell me what can you ask a better
question than i asked
yeah ask a great question answer that
one i i i i'm you know just gonna
you know phrase it in the terms that i
want to answer
exactly right brilliant please
you know where are we today and you know
what happens next
uh and what does it take to go beyond
phoenix and was it what does it take
uh to get this technology to more places
and more people
around the world right so
our next big
area of focus is exactly that
uh larger scale commercialization and
just you know scaling up
uh if
i think about you know the main
and your phoenix gives us that platform
it gives us that foundation
of upon which we can build them
and it's there are
few really challenging aspects
of this whole problem that you have to
pull together in order
to you know build the technology in
order to
deploy it uh into the field to
go from a driverless car
to a fleet of cars that are providing a
service
and then all the way to you know
commercialization so
uh and then you know this is what we
have in phoenix we've taken the
technology
from uh a proof point to an actual
deployment
and have taken our driver you know from
uh you know one card to a fleet that can
provide a service
beyond that if i think about what it
will take to
scale up and deploy in
you know more places with more customers
i
tend to think about three
main dimensions three main axes of scale
one is the core technology you know the
hardware
and software core capabilities of our
driver
the second dimension is
evaluation and deployment and the third
one
is the you know product commercial and
operational excellence so you can talk
you know
uh a bit about where we are along you
know each one of those three dimensions
about where we are today
and you know what has what will happen
next
um on you know the core technology
on you know the hardware and software
and together comprise of driver
we you know obviously have that
foundation
that is providing fully driverless trips
to our customers as we speak
in fact and we've learned
a tremendous amount from that
so now what we're doing is we are
incorporating all those lessons
into some pretty fundamental
improvements in our core technology both
on the hardware side and on the software
side
to build a more general more robust
solution
that then will enable us to massively
scale you know beyond phoenix
so on the hardware side
all of those lessons are now
incorporated into this fifth generation
hardware platform
that is you know uh being deployed right
now
and that's the platform the fourth
generation the thing that we have right
now
driving in phoenix it's good enough to
operate operate fully driverlessly you
know
night and day in various speeds and
various conditions
but the fifth generation is the platform
upon which we want to go to massive
scale
we it in turn we've really made
qualitative improvements in terms of
the capability of the system the
simplicity of the architecture the
reliability of the redundancy
it is designed to be manufacturable at
very large scale and you know provides
the right unit economics
so that's that's the next big step for
us um on the hardware side
that's that's already there for scale
the version five that's right
and is that uh coincidence or should we
look into it conspiracy theory that's
the same version as the pixel phone
is that what's the harder they can
neither confirm okay
all right cool so sorry so that's the
okay that's that axis what else
uh so similarly uh hardware is a very
discrete
jump but you know similar to the uh that
to how we're making that change from the
fourth generation
hardware to the fifth we're making
similar improvements on the software
side to make it more you know robust and
more general and allow us to kind of
quickly uh scale beyond phoenix so that
that's the first dimension of core
technology the second dimension is
evaluation and deployment
now how do you measure
your system how do you evaluate it how
do you build a release and deployment
process
where you know with confidence you can
you know regularly release new versions
of your driver
into a fleet how do you get good at it
so that
it is not you know a huge tax on your
researchers and engineers that you know
so you can how do you build all these
you know processes
the frameworks the simulation the
evaluation the data science the
validation
so that you know people can focus on
improving the system and kind of the
releases
just go out the door and get deployed
across the fleet uh so we've gotten
really good at that
in phoenix that's been a tremendously
difficult problem
but that's what we have uh in phoenix
right now that gives us that foundation
and now we're working on kind of
incorporating all the lessons that we've
learned
uh to make it more efficient to go to
new places you know scale up and just
kind of you know stamp things out
uh so that's that second dimension of
evaluation and deployment
and the third dimension is uh product
commercial and operational excellence
right and again
phoenix there is providing
an incredibly valuable platform you know
that's why we're doing things
to end in phoenix we're learning as you
know we discussed a little earlier today
a tremendous amount of really valuable
lessons from our users getting really
incredible feedback
and we'll continue to iterate on that
and incorporate all those uh those
lessons
into making our product you know even
better and more convenient for our users
so you you're converting this whole
process of phoenix in phoenix into uh
something that could be copy and pasted
elsewhere so like
uh perhaps you didn't think of it that
way when you were doing the
experimentation phoenix but
so how long did basically
you can correct me but you've i mean
it's still early days but you're taking
the full journey
in phoenix right as you were saying of
like what it takes to
basically automate i mean it's not the
entirety of phoenix right
but i imagine it can encompass the
entirety of phoenix
that's some some uh near-term date but
that's not even perhaps
important like as long as it's a large
enough geographic area
so what how
copy-pastable is that process currently
and how do like um
you know like when you copy and paste in
in uh
in google docs i think no in in or in
word
you can like apply source formatting or
apply destination formatting
so when you copy and paste uh the
phoenix
into like say boston
uh how do you apply the destination
formatting
like how much of the core of the entire
process
of bringing an actual public
transportation autonomous transportation
service to a city
is there in phoenix that you understand
enough to copy and paste into boston
or wherever um so we're not quite there
yet
we're not at a point where we're kind of
massively copy and pasting
all over the place uh but phoenix
what you know we did in phoenix and we
very intentionally have chosen phoenix
as our in our first full deployment
uh area you know exactly for that reason
to kind of tease the problem apart
look at each dimension and focus on the
fundamentals of complexity and
de-risking
you know those dimensions and then
bringing the entire thing together to
get
all the way and force ourselves to learn
all those hard lessons
on technology hardware and software on
the evaluation deployment
on operating a service operating a
business using
actually serving our customers all the
way so that we're fully informed
about the most difficult most important
challenges
to get us to that next step of massive
copy and pasting
as as you said uh and
uh that's what we're doing right now
we're incorporating all those things
that we learned
into that next system that then will
allow us to kind of copy and paste all
over the place and to massively scale to
you know more users and
more locations and you know just talked
a little bit about you know what does
that mean along those
different dimensions so on the hardware
side for example again it's that
switch from the fourth to the fifth
generation and the fifth generation is
designed to kind of have that property
can you say what other cities you're
thinking about like i'm thinking about
sorry we're in san francisco now i
thought i want to move to san francisco
but i'm thinking about moving to austin
um
i don't know why people are not being
very nice about san francisco currently
for maybe it's a small it's like maybe
it's in vogue right now
but uh austin seems i visited there and
it was uh
i was in a walmart it's funny these
moments
like turn your life there's this very
nice
woman with kind eyes just like stopped
and said uh he looks so handsome in that
tie honey
to me this has never happened to me in
my life but just the sweetness of this
woman
is something i've never experienced
certainly on the streets of boston but
even in san francisco where people
wouldn't
that's just not how they speak or think
i don't know there's a warmth to uh to
austin that love
and since waymo does have a little bit
of a history there
is that a possibility is this your
version of asking the question of like
you know dimitri i know you can't share
your commercial
and deployment roadmap but i'm thinking
about moving to should i
cisco austin like you know blink twice
if you think i should move to him
yeah that's true this room you got me
well you know we've been
testing and all over the place i think
we've been testing more in
25 cities uh we drive in san francisco
we drive in
you know michigan for snow uh we we are
doing significant amount of testing in
the bay area including san francisco
which is not like because we're talking
about the very different thing which is
like
a full-on large geographic area
public service uh you you can't share
any
okay
what about moscow is that when is that
happening
take on uh yandex i'm not paying
attention to those folks
they're doing you know there's there's a
lot of fun
i mean maybe as a way of a question
you didn't speak to sort of like
policy or like is there tricky things
with government
and so on like
is there other friction that you've
encountered
except sort of technological friction of
solving this very difficult problem is
there other stuff that you have to
overcome
when when uh deploying a public service
in a city
that's interesting it's very important
so
we we put significant effort in
uh creating those partnerships and you
know those
relationships with governments at all
levels
you know local governments
municipalities you know state level
federal level
uh we've been engaged in very deep
conversations from the earliest days of
our
you know uh projects uh whenever at all
of these levels you know whenever we go
to test uh or you know operate in a
new area you know we always lead with
with a conversation with the local
officials and but the result of that
that investment
is that no it's not challenges we have
to overcome it but it is a very
important
that we continue to have this
conversation
you